Kopftuch Eklat beim CNN Interview die
star-journalistin Christian Armen poor
sie wurde einfach sitzen gelassen vom
iranischen Präsidenten und zwar weil sie
sich fürs Interview logischerweise nicht
den Regeln des islamischen Regimes
anpassen wollte
eine star-journalistin ein geplantes
Interview und ein Lehrer Stuhl hier
sollte eigentlich eher sitzen
irans Präsident Ibrahim reisi alles ist
von langer Hand vorbereitet doch der
Iraner lässt die cnn-chef
Korrespondentin Christian
in New York als CNN Frau
die preisgekrönte Journalistin schreibt
bei Twitter 40 Minuten nach dem
geplanten Beginn des Gesprächs kam ein
Berater zu mir der Präsident sagte er
schlug vor dass ich ein Kopftuch trage
doch Aman pur sagt natürlich nein kein
Kopftuch ich habe höflich abgelehnt wir
sind in New York wo es keine Gesetze
oder Tradition in Bezug auf Kopftücher
gibt und amancour schreibt weiter ich
ließ darauf hin dass kein früherer
iranischer Präsident dies verlangt hat
wenn ich ihn außerhalb Irans interviewt
habe tatsächlich die CNN Journalistin
interviewte auch bereits die iranischen
Präsidenten Arman in der George und
rohani stets ohne Kopftuch jetzt der
Eklat und das inmitten der Woche in der
das Kopftuch im Iran für
bürgerkriegsähnliche Szenen sorgt
Frauen protestieren im Iran seit Tagen
mutig in den Straßen gegen die
Kleidervorschriften der Sittenwächter
sie verbrennen öffentlich ihre
Kopftücher Anlass der Tod von Martha
armini eine Frau die das Kopftuch nicht
vorschriftsmäßig tragen wollte und
daraufhin niedergeprügelt wurde jetzt
zeigt CNN Frau Ammann pur dem Iran was
die freie Welt vom Kopftuch hält
besonders brisant Armatur selbst hat
iranische Wurzeln verbrachte dort ihre
Kindheit ehe ihre Eltern vor der
islamischen Revolution aus dem Land
fliehen mussten
für ein Interview mit dem iranischen
Präsident reisi hätte es also keine
bessere Interviewerin gegeben doch reisi
ließ Arman pur einfach sitzen
[Musik]